first of all i mean
i'll probably do it in the introduction
but you're uh
one of the great robotics people at mit
you're a professor at mit you've
teach them a lot of amazing courses you
run a large group
and you have a important history for mit
i think as
being a part of the darpa robotics
challenge can you
maybe first say what is the darpa
robotics challenge and then
tell your story around it your journey
with it yeah sure um
so the darpa robotics challenge it came
on the tales of the darpa
grand challenge and darpa urban
challenge which were the
challenges that brought us put a
spotlight on self-driving
cars
gill pratt was at darpa and
pitched a new challenge that involved
disaster response
it didn't explicitly require humanoids
although humanoids came into the picture
this happened shortly after the
fukushima disaster
in japan and our challenge was motivated
roughly by that
because that was a case where if we had
had robots that were ready to be sent in
there's a chance that we could have
averted disaster
and certainly after the um in the
disaster response
there were times we would love we would
have loved to have sent robots in
so in practice what we ended up with was
a
a grand challenge a darpa robotics
challenge
um where boston dynamics was
uh was to make humanoid robots
people like me and the the amazing team
at mit
were competing first in a simulation
challenge
to try to be one of the ones that wins
the right to work on
one of the uh the boston dynamics
humanoids in order to compete in
the the final challenge which was a
physical challenge
and at that point it was already so it
was decided as humanoid robots
there were there were two tracks there
you could enter as a hardware team where
you brought your own robot
or you could enter through the virtual
robotics challenge as a software team
that would try to win the right to use
one of the boston dynamics robots which
are called
atlas atlas humanoid robots yeah it was
a 400 pound
marvel but a you know pretty big scary
looking
robot expensive too expensive at the
time yeah
okay so uh i mean how did you feel
at the prospect of this kind of
challenge i mean it seems
you know autonomous vehicles yeah i
guess that sounds hard
but uh not really from a robotics
perspective it's like
didn't they do in the 80s is the kind of
feeling i would have
uh like when you first look at the
problem it's on wheels but like
humanoid robots that sounds really hard
uh
so what like what what are your the
psychologically speaking what were you
feeling excited
scared why the heck did you get yourself
involved in this kind of
messy challenge we didn't really know
for sure what we were signing up for
in the sense that you could have
something that as it was described in
the call for
participation that could have put a huge
emphasis on
the dynamics of walking and not falling
down and walking over rough terrain
or the same description because the
robot had to go into this disaster area
and
turn valves and and pick up a drill
cut the hole through a wall it had to do
some interesting things
the challenge could have really
highlighted perception
and autonomous planning
or it ended up that you know locomoting
over complex
terrain played a pretty big role in the
competition
so and the degree of autonomy wasn't
clear
the decree of autonomy was always a
central part of the discussion
so um what wasn't clear was how we would
be able
how far we'd be able to get with it so
the idea was always
that you want semi-autonomy that you
want the robot
to have enough compute that you can have
a degraded network link to a human
and so the same way you we had degraded
networks
at many natural disasters you'd send
your robot in
you'd be able to get a few bits back and
forth but you don't get to have
enough potentially to fully uh operate
the robot
in every joint of the robot so and then
the question was
and the gamesmanship of the organizers
was to figure out what we're capable of
push us as far as we could
so that um it would differentiate the
teams that
put more autonomy on the robot and had a
few clicks and just said go there do
this go there do this versus someone
who's picking
every footstep or something like that so
what were some memories
painful triumphant from the experience
like what was that journey maybe
if you can dig in a little deeper maybe
even on the technical side and the team
side that that whole process of um
from the early idea stages to actually
competing
i mean this was a defining experience
for me i i
it was it came at the right time for me
in my career i had gotten tenure before
i was
due a sabbatical and most people do
something you know relaxing and
restorative
for sabbatical so you got tenure before
the the before this
yeah yeah yeah it was a good time for me
i had i had we had a bunch of algorithms
that we
were very happy with we wanted to see
how far we could push them and this was
a chance to really test our metal
to do more proper software engineering
the team we all just worked our butts
off
we you know we're in that lab almost all
the time
okay so there i mean there were some of
course high highs and low lows
throughout that
uh anytime you're you know not sleeping
and devoting your life to a 400 pound
humanoid
um i remember actually one funny
moment where we're all super tired and
so atlas had to walk across cinder
blocks that was one of the obstacles
and i remember atlas was powered down
and hanging limp you know on the on its
harness
and the the humans were there like
laying you know picking up and laying
the brick down so that the robot could
walk over it and i thought what is wrong
with this
you know we've got a robot just watching
us do all the manual labor so that it
can take its little
um stroll across the train but
i mean even the even the virtual
robotics challenge was was
super nerve-wracking and dramatic i
remember
um so so we were using gazebo as a
simulator
uh on the cloud there was all these
interesting challenges i think
the investment that osrs fc whatever
they were called
at that time brian gurkey's team at open
source robotics
they were pushing on the capabilities of
gazebo in order to scale it to the
complexity
of these challenges so um
you know up to the virtual competition
so the virtual competition
was you will sign on at a certain time
and we'll have a network connection to
another
machine on the cloud that is running the
simulator of your robot
and your controller will run on this
comp this controller this computer and
and
the physics will run on the other and
you have to connect
now um the physics they wanted it to run
at real time rates
because there was an element of human
interaction and
humans could if you do want to tell the
op it works way better if it's at
frame rate oh cool but it was very hard
to simulate these
comp these complex scenes at real-time
rate
so right up to like days before the
competition
the the simulator wasn't quite
at real-time rate and that was great for
me because my controller
was solving a big pretty big
optimization problem and it wasn't quite
at real-time rate so i was fine
i was keeping up with the simulator we
were both running at about 0.7
and i remember getting this email and by
the way the perception
folks on our team hated that they knew
that if my controller was too slow
the robot was going to fall down and and
you know no matter how good their
perception system was if i can't make my
controller fast enough
anyways we get this email like three
days before the virtual competition
you know it's for all the marbles we're
gonna either get a humanoid robot or
we're not
and we get an email saying good news we
made the robot does the simulator faster
it's now one point and uh
we're i was just like oh man what are we
gonna do here so yeah
um that came in late at night for me um
a few days ahead a few days ahead i went
over there was
it happened that frank permentor who's a
a very very sharp
he's a he was a student at the time um
working on optimization
was he was still in lab uh frank we need
to make
the quadratic programming solver faster
not like a little faster it's actually
you know
um and we wrote a new solver for that
qp together that night
and you saw terrifying so there's a
really hard optimization problem
that you're constantly solving you
didn't make the optimization problem
simpler
you you wrote a new solver so um i mean
your observation is almost spot-on well
what we
did was what everybody i mean people
know how to do this but we had not yet
done
this idea of warm starting so we are
solving a big optimization problem
at every time step but if you're running
fast enough the optimization problem
you're solving on the last time step
is pretty similar to the optimization
you're going to solve with the next we
had course had told
our commercial solver to use warm
starting but even the interface
to that commercial solver was causing us
these delays
so what we did was we basically wrote we
called it fastqp at the time
we wrote a very lightweight very fast
layer
which would basically check if nearby
solutions to the quadratic program
were which were very easily checked uh
could stabilize the robot
and if they couldn't we would fall back
to the solver you couldn't really test
this well right um
so we always knew that if we fell back
if we it got to the point where if for
some reason things slowed down and we
fell back to the original solver
the robot would actually literally fall
down um
so it was it was a harrowing sort of
edge weird ledge we were
sort of on but i mean it actually like
the
the 400 pound humidity could come
crashing to the ground if you if you if
your solver is not fast enough
but you know that we have lots of good
experiences
so can i ask you a weird question i
i get um about the idea of hard work
so um actually people
like students of yours that i've
interacted with
and just and robotics people in general
but they uh they have
moments at moments have worked harder
than
uh most people i know in terms of if you
look at different disciplines of how
hard people work
but they're also like the happiest like
just like
i don't know um it's the same thing with
like running people that push themselves
to like the limit
they all also seem to be like the most
like full of life somehow
uh and i get often criticized like
you're not getting enough sleep
what are you doing to your body blah
blah blah like
this kind of stuff and i usually just
kind of respond like
i'm i'm doing what i love i'm passionate
about i
i love it i feel like it's it's
invigorating i actually think
i don't think the lack of sleep is what
hurts you i think what hurts you is uh
stress and lack of doing things that
you're passionate about but in this
world
yeah i mean can you comment about uh
why the heck robotics people are
[Laughter]
willing to push themselves to that
degree is there value in that
and why are they so happy i think
i think you got it right i mean i think
the causality is not
that we work hard and i think other
disciplines work very hard too
but it's i don't think it's that we work
hard and therefore we are happy
i think we found something that we're
truly passionate about
it makes us very happy and then we
get a little involved with it and spend
a lot of time on it
what a luxury to have something that you
want to spend all your time on
right we could talk about this for many
hours but
maybe if we could pick is there
something on the technical side on the
approach that you took that's
interesting
that turned out to be a terrible failure
or a success that you carry into your
work today
about all the different ideas that were
involved
in um making whether in the in the
simulation or in the in the real world
making this semi-autonomous system work
i mean it really did teach me
something fundamental about what it's
going to take to get robustness out of a
system of this complexity
i would say the darpa challenge really
was foundational in my thinking i think
the autonomous driving community thinks
about this i think lots of
people thinking about safety critical
systems that might have machine learning
in the loop
are thinking about these questions for
me the darpa challenge was the moment
where i realized
you know we've spent every waking minute
running this robot
and again in for the physical
competition days before the competition
we saw the robot fall down in a way
it had never fallen down before i
thought
you know how could we have found that
you know we only have one robot
it's running almost all the time we just
didn't have enough hours in the day
to test that robot something has to
change right
and then i think that i mean i would say
that the team that won
uh was was from kaist was the team that
had
two robots and was able to do not only
incredible engineering just absolutely
top-rate engineering but also they were
able to test
at a rate and um discipline that we
didn't
keep up with what does testing look like
what are we talking about here like
what's
what's a a loop of test like a
from start to finish what is a loop of
testing yeah i mean i think
there's a whole philosophy to testing
there's the unit tests and you can do
that on a hardware you can do that in a
small piece of code
you write one function you should write
a test that that checks that functions
input
outputs you should also write an
integration test at the other extreme of
of running the whole system together you
know where that
that try to turn on all the different
functions that you've
you think are correct it's much harder
to write the specifications for a system
level test especially
if that system is as complicated as a
humanoid robot but the philosophy is
sort of the same
i'm the real robot it's it's no
different but
on a real robot it's impossible to run
the same experiment twice
so if you if you see a failure
you hope you caught something in the
logs that tell you what happened
but you'd probably never be able to run
exactly that experiment again
and right now
i think our philosophy is just
basically monte carlo estimation is just
run as many experiments as we can maybe
try to set up the environment
to to make the things we are worried
about
happen as often as possible but really
we're relying on
somewhat random search in order to test
maybe that's all we'll ever be able to
but i think
you know because there's an argument
that the things that will get you are
the
things that are really nuanced in the
world and it'll be very hard to for
instance put back in a simulation
you